so i'm talking to elon again soon
i'm curious to get your perspective on
it
if i wanted to talk to him about tic tac
about
these weird out-there propulsion
ideas which are obviously just like you
said if there's something to it
if it can be investigated somehow it
would be extremely useful
for us to understand in the effort of
developing propulsion systems that can
get us cheaply to
out to space what what should elon
think about this stuff what should he do
what should people like him
i think people need to open their
aperture up and stay off of
uh take the next step and go you know we
are tied to fuels and either solid
rocket or liquid
you know whatever we do but it's it's a
thrust generated where we rapidly expand
gas to create thrust
which is really in layman's terms you
know we can get into what but
that's what it does um if you have
something that
you can contain that is a
as a fuel source that would last a
significant
amount of time you know those rocket
boosters go and when they're done
they're done
there's enough to get them back down
that's it there's not a huge you know
not coming back and go oh i still got
three quarters of a tank let's hold him
on and do it again
his system's not doing that um
but you know the way the way contracting
especially in the government the
government has tons of money but you got
to remember the the government has to
justify how they spend our tax dollars
for the most part there's times where
they can
hide money in the budget to get stuff
done but then when you look at and i'm
just going to throw a few out there but
if you look at
what amazon you know does with bezos
and you've got elon there's some
there's some big money out there i mean
you're talking you know
bezos alone could buy companies like big
companies
apple is another one these companies had
huge huge amounts of money
and then just go over to the gates
foundation and they've got
gazillions and gazillions of dollars
we've got universities there's so much
money out there if we
really wanted to do it aside from what
the government wants to do because we do
live in a free society
i think there's enough to go how do we
do this and
because when you work outside of what
the government would want to do
let's so let's let's we're not working
on this necessarily for the united
states although i am a huge
giant i will be american i would never
yeah i am an american you're talking to
somebody born in the soviet union i
can't believe you agreed to this
um but but when i you know you haven't
killed me yet
yeah well you're here yeah and you've
been here for a while
no no i'm joking i'm an american citizen
i'm actually pretty much
american but see when you do that so you
look at let's just look at american
universities
yes so there's some brilliant minds and
we'll just use mit because you work down
there
there's some brilliant minds but there's
a huge chunk of those brilliant minds
that are not american citizens so if you
want to get into
government stuff and you are not an
american citizen it gets really really
really hard
but if i take money like bezos money
elon money
and they let's just say they want to
work together they can split it up 50 50
the two of them when the technology gets
developed but now i'm not constrained by
who has to do the work i just want to
make sure that i try and keep it in the
united states because
technology is technology and if it gets
developed and gets over to where
you know a country gets a hold of it and
then just basically uses it for their
own because you save them all the
research time
uh you don't want to do that but if we
can get to the point where we can we do
it on the international space station we
realize that space was too expensive
for one country to do alone so we made
the international space station and we
have a
conglomerate it's the one thing that the
russians in the u.s
actually work together on think about it
that's it we work together on space
because we realize it's way too
expensive for us to do alone
and effective so we've got this thing
that's been out there floating around
for god now what is it like 20 years
that thing's been up there floating
around
so it's getting old we're gonna have to
replace parts and do stuff but
if we can pull the money together and
come up with a something that would
literally change mankind and change
travel and allow us to actually do a
more effective thing of exploring
because if you develop that technology
i'm not you don't even have to send a
man person if you can develop a
technology that's
so with our automation and we're
progressing in our
our computing power to send something
out that's not just floating around
when you know that it can react a lot
quicker something that could actually go
down to the surface and come back up so
right now everything we get out of mars
it goes down there and then it just
sends data back it analyzes it
but i've got a technology that can go up
there really quick i'm not worried about
man i don't have life support systems
and all that but it can go down it can
go it can cruise around
it can hover above it can take samples
and it can actually take martian soil
and then bring it
back yeah so we can analyze it here
that's a game changer
it's a complete game changer because it
opens up all the planets
exactly so in the sense that the the tic
tac
is a symbol so uh whatever you think
even from a debunking perspective
there's a non-zero probability that it's
alien technology
and in that sense it serves as a
beacon of hope and a reason
to like you said widen the aperture and
to invest
big amounts of money into thinking
outside the box like
it's almost a hope
to say we can do better propulsion
we can overcome physics in an order of
magnitude better way
and it's worthwhile to try i think and i
don't think the money if you look at the
big picture with the amount of money
some that's out there floating around
these private companies
you know i think if you said hey i've
got let's just say 100 million dollars
which really a hundred million dollars
relative to
bezos has got 100 and some billion
dollars in the network so if he said hey
100 100 million dollars you drop 100
million dollars and i go
and i'm going to put a you know like the
government will send a
broad area announcement out that says
hey we're looking for this technology or
a darpa
program but what if i just said hey
who's to stop
bezos and elon from doing that on their
own to say hey i want to go pool
universities because they have fewer
restrictions
because it's not tax dollars they don't
have the checks and bound they can do
whatever they want so their money
oh sorry about that um to go hey i'm
going to put this out and i'm going to
get the best
physicists that are working at cern that
are at mit that are at caltech at the
schools i mentioned and
oh by the way a few of these guys are
propulsion experts and i'm going to
basically
i'm going to fund you guys for 10 years
so you get 10 million dollars a year and
i'm going to give your salaries and
we're going to do that or whatever the
amount works so let's cut it down to 5
so we can pay you well
right to do the research but oh by the
way the research is
it's not classified but it's controlled
so we're not going to publicly just put
this out in journals but if we make a
leap
that we think would advance because
although those let's say there's 10 of
them
those 10 scientists come up with
something and they put out a paper
there might be another a number 11 at
another university that reads that paper
and says hey
i kind of had this idea and now you can
get a thought pool that pushes us in
and gets us out of the the mindset
because we have a tendency to
we evolved the stuff that we create but
yeah it's like i was joking because you
know
i i know a ton of guys with phds and
girls
and i said but you know how much when a
person gets a phd in like engineering
how much new math is really being done i
said there's a handful of people in the
world that are really doing i'm talking
i'm talking stephen hawkins type
brilliance that is going
i'm really doing something that's yeah
that's totally
different that's a big dramatic thing
now going on in physics that
everyone is just everybody's converse
towards this local
minima or local maximum whatever you
think about it and
it's it's again same as with the tic tac
thinking outside the box is not
is uh not accepted and it probably
should be
but it's hard because if you go back go
back to einstein
back to the original he was the he was
out of the box
yeah he did not think that the true
jesus had he not
thought out of the box and came up with
some of his theories where would we be
you